BRAD ABRAMS: Good afternoon
and welcome to Google I/O.
Thank you for coming
to this session.
I'm Brad Abrams.
I'm a product manager on
the Cloud platform team.
MANDY WAITE: And
hello, I'm Mandy Waite.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform.
BRAD ABRAMS: And in
this session we're
going to give you a whirlwind
tour of the Google Cloud
platform.
What I love about
I/O is we get to talk
about what's next, not
just what's next for Google
or what's next for the cloud
but what's next for all of us
as developers.
And as software
developers we know
that we are in one of
the most high stakes,
critical, creative
industries on the planet.
And it's that way because
our users, the people that
use our apps, continually
push us to build
better software faster.
Users want our applications
to be highly available
24 hours a day, seven
days a week in every geo
around the world.
And those users demand
our applications
be fast and responsive.
Our studies have shown
latency on the orders of tens
or hundreds of milliseconds
can have a significant drop
off rate engagement
on your apps.
And increasingly
users want to be
delighted by having you
predict and suggest,
to offer them things before
they even know they need them.
So whether you're at an
enterprise or you're at a start
up or you work at Google, we
all face the same challenge.
And that is we want to build
better software faster.
So let's talk about
how the Google Cloud
platform helps you build
that better software faster.
With GCP we're building a
different kind of cloud.
Some of you may be familiar
with the status quo clouds
and they share a lot in
common with co load data
centers of the past.
Now you may not be physically
plugging in network cables
or switching out hard
drives, but you're still
doing a lot of unproductive
infrastructure work.
And that's time that
can be better spent
focused on your application,
the unique value you have.
Google used to have a data
center cloud like that
internally up until
about 10 years ago.
And user demand really spiked.
Our usage really started
spiking on all our apps.
And we realized we
just couldn't keep up
with the scale with that
kind of data center.
And so today if you're a Googler
on Gmail or YouTube or apps,
if you're a developer
on one of those,
you may never write
a deployment script
but your application may
be deployed over hundreds
or even thousands of instances.
You may never spin up an
instance or even SSH into one,
but your application is
used by tens of millions
of people every day.
And you may never
write a failover code,
but your applications are some
of the most highly reliable
applications on the internet.
And that's because
we've rethought
what it is to be a cloud
from top to bottom.
And it's that journey that
we're on with the Google Cloud
platform, to have
you be able to use
the exact same infrastructure,
tools, and services that we
use internally.
And that's what we think of
as this third wave of cloud
computing.
And to help you get a sense,
a really hands on sense
as developers, there's
nothing like code
to help you understand.
So in order to do
that, Mandy and I
over the course of this talk
are going to build an app.
And it's the next hit mobile
game called photo scavenger
hunt.
And we're launching
it here at this event.
You can go to the Play Store
right now and download it.
The way it works is
you're given four clues.
And then you go out
into the real world
and take pictures of items
to try to match those clues.
And when you match
the clues, you
get the point
associated with it.
The architecture of the
application is very simple.
There is an Android and
iOS client application.
Now there's a lot
of talks here at I/O
talking about the
client apps so we're not
going to spend a lot of
time there although that's
very important.
What we're going to do is focus
on the server side of the app.
So the server side of the
app is on App Engine app
written in Node.js.
How many Node.js
developers do we have here?
OK.
A good number.
Most of what we're showing works
in many, many other languages,
PHP Python, Ruby, Java.
So if you use other
languages, you
can apply almost
everything we're showing.
The photo gets uploaded and
it's stored in cloud storage.
And that's our object storage,
highly reliable, highly
available object storage.
We store a state about the
game in Google's NoSQL database
called Cloud Datastore.
And then we do the smarts of
it with a vision API where we
apply the same sort of machine.
We use exactly the same machine
learning technology that's
used in the Google Photos app is
available to you as a developer
and we're going to show
you how that works.
So I think the best way
though to understand this app
is actually to see a demo.
So could we switch over to the
demo machine, to the phone.
And are we seeing it?
Yeah.
No.
Can we switch to this?
OK.
He's working on
switching to this.
So while we're waiting
how many of you
are already using Google
Cloud Platform, App Engine
or Compute Engine or something?
OK, good.
And how many are using
another cloud provider?
A god number of you.
So thank you for coming.
I appreciate you
being open minded
about your cloud choices.
Certainly the future I think
is in heterogeneous clouds.
And hopefully you'll
see that in this demo.
MANDY WAITE: All right.
For this demo you have
to download the app
and do it yourself.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
What you need to do
is download the app.
Should we press on
and come back to this?
Give him one more minute.
Why don't we-- Yeah.
So he's going to
keep working on it.
While he's working
on it, Mandy is
going to show how to actually
build the application.
And we'll pop back
and show you the app.
MANDY WAITE: Right.
OK.
So I need to get in here.
So you haven't seen the app
but it is really impressive
unless you've downloaded
it in which case
you're playing with it now.
And it's pretty awesome.
So we're going to
use-- well, we're
going to do some live
coding basically.
I'm going to use snippets today.
I'm going to cheat because
my cutting and pasting is
really laborious.
Also my typing is terrible.
So I just make mistakes
all over the place.
And it wouldn't work.
How many of you are using
Sublime Text as a developer
tool?
Fantastic.
How many of you are using Atom?
OK.
All right.
Good.
So all you see is Atom--
I'm using Sublime again now.
OK.
So here we have a very
simple Node.js application.
We have all of our
requires at the top here.
We won't get too much
detail about those.
What we care about is doing
development the Google Cloud
platform.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh.
Should we do the app real quick?
MANDY WAITE: Oh, yeah.
OK.
Let's go for it.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Great.
And then we'll switch
right back to her honestly.
OK.
So as I mentioned--
MANDY WAITE: He's always
stealing my thunder.
BRAD ABRAMS: You get four clues.
In this case, person-- sorry
let me leave it-- person,
wedding ring, flower, dog.
Does anybody have a dog I
could take a-- a flower?
OK.
How about I use person.
So I'm just going
to click on Person.
OK.
Sorry.
I'm just going to
click on Person.
OK.
Just one sec.
Oh, and now the app-- OK.
OK.
MANDY WAITE: You
wrote it by the way.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
MANDY WAITE: It wasn't me.
BRAD ABRAMS: Unbelievable.
OK we're going to
come back to the demo
for a different reason.
OK, press on.
MANDY WAITE: All right.
OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: I'll fix it.
MANDY WAITE: Do you
want to use mine?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
We can do yours if you want.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: So that's the
benefit of Android and iOS.
No?
MANDY WAITE: Wow.
Technical difficulties
everywhere.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
MANDY WAITE: Here you go.
So I'm going to click on Person
and take my selfie on stage
here.
So I switch the camera.
And I take my selfie.
And then I'll put it here.
And what's happening now,
hopefully you can see.
MANDY WAITE: I'm sorry about
my fingerprints on my phone.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
what we're doing now
is sending that--
I hope this works.
Yeah-- oh, goodness.
MANDY WAITE: Hey, you guys
have killed the internet.
BRAD ABRAMS: We send
it off to the server.
And then it comes back and tells
us what it found in the image.
Let's just press on.
MANDY WAITE: Let's talk
about how it--I'm sorry.
BRAD ABRAMS: Switch
back to the--
MANDY WAITE: All right.
OK.
So we have some
Node.js code here.
And what we're going
to do is use something
called the Google Cloud
client library which
gives very, very simple
programmatic access
to pretty much everything
in Google Cloud Platform.
OK.
And it's really,
really easy to use.
These libraries are handcrafted
and they are very idiomatic.
We had them for seven languages.
And when you
develop with them it
feels very, very comfortable
and very, very second nature.
Very similar to what you
would do normally when
you're developing in that
language which isn't always
the case with API's.
The first thing we need
to do is actually-- well,
we've actually installed this
client library called Gcloud,
MPM installed Gcloud before.
And now what we need to
do is require Gcloud.
And that gives us
back an object we
can use to access all Google
Cloud Platform services.
We've also done some credential
munge in here as well.
We've set an
environment variable
with a key file, a file that
contains some JSON code, that
contains our credentials.
So it's very much,
very, very much
to simplify the
authentication process.
The authentication
process is really simple.
So once we have this
object now what we can do
is go to step two.
And we can get a reference
to Google Cloud Storage.
I'm now going to use Google
Cloud Storage to basically
when the apps working,
which it will be soon,
basically to upload
images from the phone,
from the application,
and so that we can then
pass it on to the
cloud vision API which
will do the processing.
For this we call
Gcloud.storage and we
get a reference
back to an object
called storage which we
can use to make calls on.
We also access a bucket.
This is a cloud storage.
It's an object based
store for large amounts
of unstructured data.
And to access it
we need buckets.
So we have a bucket
we created earlier.
I'm passing this
[INAUDIBLE] environment.
We have an environment
variable called Upload bucket.
So we called it storage.bucket
and then the name
and we get back a
reference for our bucket.
In step three, which is
the first part of our API,
so we've only got a
simple part of the API
that the application calls here.
And this is the API
image and the game ID.
The game ID we will use
randomly throughout the talk.
But that's the API
we're going to call.
And we're going to be
basically uploading
the photograph to that.
A picture that is
taken from the app.
And to do that, to get
started, very simply,
in this case very simply
we'd like to type step three.
We type in a few lines of code.
So basically we create
a storage path variable,
which is the path
where we're going
to store the uploaded image.
And then we create an
options object which
contains that information.
Then we can just simply
call bucket upload.
The path of the file
has been uploaded.
We're using Malta in Node.js
which does the uploads for us.
And then we passing in the
options object and the callback
function.
Ultimately, double
upload the file.
If there is a problem,
we'll get the error back
and we can express that
back to the console.
Or in this case,
we're just going
to say cancel.log
uploaded to cloud storage.
And so I'm going to save that
and then go to my thumbnail
here.
And I'm going to run
nodemon app-demo.js.
And so basically we're
listening for changes
to the application
using nodemon.
What we can do now is send an
image very much in the same way
as the application would do.
In this case we
have-- we decided
to go for something, an image
that is fairly aggressive.
You know what raccoons are like?
We don't have
raccoons in the UK.
We have them here.
And they're quite scary, right?
Raccons, yeah?
Apparently.
So what we need is
a raccoon picture.
Right.
OK, so let's use a raccoon
picture which is this one.
I think it's a little bit scary.
OK.
All right.
So OK maybe not so scary right.
OK.
So we use this one.
And what we do is we'll emit
a very simple curl command
to our endpoint locally.
And we'll send this now.
And nothing much is going
to happen because we're just
uploading a file.
I didn't actually
close the response.
But we do get our
message printed.
Uploaded to cloud storage.
Ah, file object.
I should have actually
done a string on that.
OK, so we've upload a file.
Very, very simple.
The next thing we want to do
is call a cloud vision API.
And to do that, we need access
to the cloud vision API.
So the cloud vision API
effectively allows us
to process images, send
images into the cloud.
And then get information
about what the cloud vision
API effectively sees
within that image.
And that's effectively
content detection and also
classification.
We can look for things like
labels, common objects.
We can do landmarks.
We can also see our text.
We can also detect facial
expressions as well.
And if you go to
the cloud sandbox,
we have an emoto booth
that will take your picture
and detect whether you're
happy or sad, which
most people do already anyway.
So I'm not sure what
the big deal is.
So what we need
to do here is get
a reference for our vision API.
Oh, also we can detect
inappropriate content
that has been sent up as well.
So anybody sends brute
pictures, we can detect that.
OK.
So for this we need a
reference to the vision API.
And that's step four.
Gcloud.vision gives us a
reference back to an object
we can use.
And then we do step five which
is-- oh, surprise, surprise,
step five.
And here we have some more code.
We set an arguments
object, a JSON object.
And we're going to use
two specific features.
One is the label detection,
feature of cloud vision API.
The other is the
safesearch detection.
Now the label dissection
detects things within the image,
like raccoons, angry raccoons.
We get the facial expressions
on the raccoon right?
BRAD ABRAMS: We should do that.
MANDY WAITE:
Safesearch detection
will look for
inappropriate content,
OK, and flag it if it's there.
And the image source is
just the path to the file.
This is the file that's stored
in Google Cloud Storage.
And we use Gs:// as the currency
for internal URLs within Google
Cloud Platform.
And now [INAUDIBLE] is simply
called vision.annotate.
And we pass in the
arguments objects.
We get back a results object.
And then, if we have a problem,
we echo to the console.
We do some cleanup.
We have some cheating code here,
label cleanup, which actually
does some cleanup on response.
But we basically
have a labels object
which we can stringify and
return back to the user.
OK.
So let's try it out.
And what we can do is
go back to our console.
And update available,
that's very nice.
I did that in the wrong place.
BRAD ABRAMS: Do that later.
MANDY WAITE: I'm meant
to do that in here.
It's very easy to panic when
you're doing demos right.
OK.
So we have a nodemon
running again.
And we can send our angry
raccoon picture again.
In this case, we get back a
response from the vision API.
And let's compare that
to the photograph.
So we have a mammal,
96% confidence,
and 95% chance it's an animal,
and 94% chance he's a raccoon.
And down at the bottom
here, it's very unlikely
to be adult content.
Although this could
be considered adult
content to raccoons.
I'm not sure.
BRAD ABRAMS: It's possible.
MANDY WAITE: Also
medical violence.
So it can detect that
kind of thing for us.
We're not acting on that
information, but we could do.
Do you act on it in the code?
BRAD ABRAMS: I don't.
I do actually.
I do.
MANDY WAITE: Good.
OK.
So--
BRAD ABRAMS: Test me on it.
MANDY WAITE: The last part
is to store the labels.
Now the application
is quite interesting
that it learns basically from
the images that you upload.
So every time you upload an
image, it detects labels.
And we store the labels.
And then we use those
labels to seed the game.
So the things you see, the four
options you see in the game,
are labels from
images that people
have uploaded beforehand.
So it's quite interesting
the way it works.
It's very, very dynamic.
So in order to
store labels we need
to store them somewhere safe.
Maybe another SQL,
non relational
store that scales
massively, something
like Google Cloud Datastore.
And to access that we
just do Gcloud.datastore
to get a reference
back to the data store.
And down here we can very
simply make course of that.
We iterate across the results
object here using a map.
We pull out a label.
Then we create a key.
And we look into the datastore
to say do you have this key?
If we get a response back
saying, yes, we will increment.
I haven't actually
implemented the code.
We will increment the
counts on that label.
If we don't get
the label back, we
will create a label
with a count of one
and push it back
to the data store.
And so that way the game
is constantly learning.
And last thing we do is
very quickly because Brad
is getting impatient on me.
We'll quickly run that again.
We'll save the updates and we'll
run the curl command again.
And this time we get the
same results back but now
we can see here we've actually
got the labels pulled out
from the response.
We've now stored those directly.
And that's pretty much it
for-- that's what you'll do now
is deploy the
application to Google App
Engine for the next section.
And for this I'm going to use
a tool called cloud STK which
gives a command called Gcloud.
And this is the one stop shop
for everything Google Cloud
Platform when it comes
to managing stuff.
And I'm going to type in preview
app deploy minus minus version
alpha.
We have many version but we're
using two specific versions.
Mine is alpha 1 and
we're going to say--
BRAD ABRAMS: [INAUDIBLE].
MANDY WAITE: That's it, right?
OK.
So now we're going to push
this Google App engine
and Brad's going to take over.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
So let's switch back to
the demo one last time.
MANDY WAITE: All right.
Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Back to the screen.
Do we have it?
OK.
So there we are.
You can see we the iOS working.
It knew with confidence
that I'm a person.
So 95% confident
So it uses the same
calls she just did.
And then it also
found that I'm a man
and apparently it
likes my glasses.
So there you go.
OK.
So let's switch back
to the demo machine.
And we have this application
deployed in production now.
And you're ready
to start thinking
about where you're going
to deploy your application.
So as a developer
you're ready to think
about where to deploy the app.
So we've already--
let me just jump
into the demo-- we've
already shown deploying it
to App Engine.
And in fact earlier today Mandy
deployed that to App Engine
and we ran a little
load test on it.
So all you do with App Engine
is write your source code,
deploy it up, and then we handle
all-- it's a complete no ops
environment.
So you don't have to do
anything around configuring
the database, managing
the servers, or anything.
You can see we've spiked up to
30 or 40 queries per second.
And what's nice about that is
we scaled up and we scaled down.
So you didn't have to think
about how many machines should
I provision?
How much is this going to cost?
What should my load be?
As the load came up,
more machines came up.
And when the load went away,
the machines went away.
So that's quite nice.
Another really cool
feature of App Engine
is App Engine versions.
So what I'll mention
in a minute is
we did this alpha-- I
wrote an alpha 2 version.
You saw the version
Mandy wrote with alpha 1.
I wrote an alpha 2 version
but Mandy's version
is getting all the traffic.
So if I wanted to, I could
migrate traffic to this.
I could split traffic to it.
And the way that works is
I can just scale it up.
So if I'm doing an A/B
test or actually the way
we deploy every binary
at Google in our servers
is a staged rollout.
Start at 1% go to 10%.
And that makes it make
sure it's a safe roll out.
And then the last
thing to show here
is in container, the
Google container registry.
So when Mandy deployed
that app what happened is
we actually pushed the
source code up to the server.
And then on a clean
hermetic environment
we built the node.js app
into a container image.
And then deployed that to the
Google container registry.
And then App Engine grabbed it
out of the container registry
and deployed it on to that
whole fleet of machines.
We had, I think,
30 or 40 machines
going during that load test.
And so that means that this
container image is available
right here in the container
registry right now.
MANDY WAITE: That seems a
little bit like magic to me.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, App
Engine is magical.
As a developer, you
focus on your code
and Google handles the rest.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
Well, sometimes I want to have a
little bit more control though.
I want to actually control
more this and the way--
BRAD ABRAMS: You
don't like the magic?
MANDY WAITE: I want to scale
it manually and all that stuff.
I want to take care
of it myself, right.
BRAD ABRAMS: I see.
I see.
I know a lot of developers
want more control.
And so that's why
we have Kubernetes.
I see you're wearing
a Kubernetes T-shirt.
MANDY WAITE: You're right.
How many of you are
using Kubernetes?
How many of you have
heard of Kubernetes?
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
All right.
A few.
MANDY WAITE: Kubernetes
is the next big thing.
All right.
OK.
So what we have,
we have an image.
The image we just uploaded.
And default alpha 1
is our app inversion.
And here it is in the
container registry.
So this is a private registry.
That's Google Cloud Platform
to your project specifically.
And what we have is
many different images.
The latest version is this
one, deployed one minute ago.
And that was created effectively
by the container builder.
And if we select
that, what we see here
is a show pull command.
This means we can pull the
image down from the registry
just like you would
do for [INAUDIBLE]
if you were developing
a [INAUDIBLE].
And what we can do is we
can click on this show pull
command.
And the pull command effectively
will pull it down locally
where we can run it.
In this case it's Gcloud
docker pull instead of docker
pull because we need to
do some authentication.
This is a secure registry.
So we don't want
anybody accessing it.
So in this case we do
Gcloud to do the all for us.
We also have this thing
called Running Cloud Shell.
Running Cloud
Shell will start up
a shell in the cloud
in your browser
effectively that's associated
with your Google Cloud Platform
credentials.
From this you can access
all of your projects,
all of the things you have
running in your projects
and a complete tool
chain including docker.
And what we have also deployed
is a Kubernetes cluster.
And I'll mention
Kubernetes in a second.
So here we have Gcloud
docker pull and then a path
to the image that was
uploaded by my deployment.
And I can just do--
BRAD ABRAMS: Ask for just-- OK.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
MANDY WAITE: And I can just hit
that and it would now deploy.
So what is Kubernetes?
Kubernetes effectively allows us
to run our containers anywhere.
OK.
And containers are
hard to manage.
Once you finally get
what containers are,
you start containerized
everything
and you end up
with a lot of them.
And you need some way to
manage all of that complexity.
And Kubernetes does
all of that for you.
So effectively you'll
create container images
and you'll say so
Kubernetes run this for me.
And it will run it for you.
And that's what we're
going to do now.
We have a container cluster
which we created earlier.
It's called main cluster.
It has four nodes and four
CPUs, one node per machine.
OK.
So can you see that?
Is it too small or too big?
Too big-- can't be too big.
OK.
So in order to use
this, we're not
going to go into the
details of Kubernetes
but there is a talk on Friday.
Carter Morgan is
going to be talking
about Kubernetes in detail.
And you should go
along to that talk
if you want to find out more.
But in this case, we
just do control-r.
We're going to use
to history because we
had this thing called a
deployment which effectively
manages our running
containers for us.
And now we're going to do a run.
kubeccl run and then
name of the application
which is PSH and then
the path of the image.
And also a port
number in this case.
Kubeccl is the command
for all the operations
within Kubernetes
on the command line.
OK.
So we hit that and we've
created a deployment.
And now we go back up and
do get deployments again.
We see we have one created.
So this is basically creating
one instance of that image
that we created from the
App Engine deployment.
So this is the App
Engine app that we built.
Now we're running on Kubernetes.
It's not ready yet.
It says zero available.
OK.
And now it's got one available.
So that container is
now up and running.
So what we can do now
is-- that's great.
We had that container running
in our cluster somewhere.
We don't really
know where it is.
We have four machines.
We've let's Kubernetes
take care of that for us.
What we need to do now is we
have to access it as a service.
And we have a very simple
construct called a service
to give us that access.
And we can do control-r expose.
And this command
will effectively
expose that running
container to other services
within our cluster.
It will give us
internal IP address.
Minus, minus type
equals load balance
that will effectively give us
an external IP address as well.
And we're going to
get that shortly.
So if I do kubeccl
get services, I
will see that I have a
service now called PSH
with an internal IP address.
Now any other services
I have could access that
via that stable IP address.
But ultimately we will
want an external IP address
that we can connect to
with our curl command we've
been using for demos.
And we'll wait for
that for a second.
And what we'll do
in the meantime
is scale the application.
So we have one instance
running currently.
Say we want 20
instances of that.
We want to load balance
traffic across 20 instances
of that application
that we're running.
We could do that very easily.
And we use a scale
command for that.
So the kubeccl scale
deployment which
is the thing that manages
the containers for us
and psh the name minus
minus replicas equals 20.
We hit that.
And now we can do get
deployments and we will see--
and we're not going to
wait for it because we
are in a rush--
it's now spitting up
20 instances of that
running container.
We got six so far.
We won't wait for it, but we are
interested in the external IP
address.
So we will go back to our
services, get services.
And now we can see we have
an external IP address.
OK.
So we have a cheat
sheet here which
makes life a little easier.
And my curl command that we've
used for the raccoon image
before is here.
And what we need to
do is copy and paste
in the IP address of the
service in Kubernetes.
Get back here so
we can paste it.
Lots of network latency and now
we can curl our raccoon image
back up.
The end point here we
have 42 as the game
ID effectively, that
last part of the URL.
And we see the results back
exactly the same as before.
BRAD ABRAMS: So I think
what Mandy-- what we just
showed you is that you can build
a standard Node.js application
using Google services.
We deployed that to
App Engine and it just
handles everything for us.
If you want more control, you
take that exact same container
image and run it with
Kubernetes also on GCE.
So--
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
Exactly.
You could also run it
somewhere else, right.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So that's very
portable, isn't it?
From one Google thing to
another Google thing, right.
It's very portable.
MANDY WAITE: That's
very portable.
What more do you want right?
BRAD ABRAMS: So actually I
was talking to people earlier
and I heard somebody mention
there's this small bookseller
in Seattle that has a cloud.
You might have heard of them.
So let's switch over and
show that real quick.
So AWS, Amazon Web
Services, has a cloud.
So what I've done is
spin up a micro instance,
we don't need to
give them much money.
And let's see if we can get
that exact same container image
running in that micro instance.
So what I'm going to do
is SSH into that machine
and hopefully I can connect.
MANDY WAITE: The
network is dead, bro.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, network is fun.
OK.
MANDY WAITE: Let's move on.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So I can connect
into this machine.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to run it in docker.
So nothing is a
running right now.
So what I can do is I'm going to
use this docker run-- actually
I'm going to do a
doctor pull first.
And so what this
is going to do is
go out to the
container registry,
download that image
onto this local machine.
We're just wrapping
the doctor command
with Gcloud for authentication.
There's other ways
to do authentication,
but it speaks the exact
same docker wire format.
And then what we're going to
do is run that docker container
right here on EC2 image.
Now we could have shown
that with Kubernetes on EC2.
That works beautifully as well.
We could have also shown
it with [INAUDIBLE].
That works well.
We could show it with
EC2 container services.
But we just wanted to shows
the very base level thing
which is just a docker image.
And so the to do that I'm
going to use this run command.
And it's kind of
a little bit fancy
because it has to handle the
authentication so it passes
in authentication credentials.
And there we have
it up and running.
And now we're going to see if
that exact same instance will
work.
See I'm hitting it in EC2
from my local machine.
And we should get the
identical results.
So what do you think?
Portability?
No?
OK.
MANDY WAITE: It is the
same raccoon, believe me.
BRAD ABRAMS: It's
the same raccoon.
MANDY WAITE: It really is.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So now what we
showed you is built.
We built the app in NodeJS.
We deployed it to App
Engine, to Kubernetes,
and to an EC2 instance.
Now let's talk about when your
application is in production.
I mentioned earlier
that I worked
on alpha 2 version
of the application
I think is a lot better.
But I'm hearing some
complaints from users
that there may be some latency
issues with my version.
And I don't think it's true
because I write good code.
So we can go in and
there's a tool in the cloud
platform called
Stackdriver Trace
and it's an RPC
profiling utility.
And it tells me where every
millisecond of latency
in the application goes.
So you can see
all these requests
are happening live right now.
I'm going to go in
though and drill in
on one particular report.
So trace has these
reports views that
lets you compare two
different releases
and look at their latency.
So you can see the version
Mandy built, alpha 1 is in blue
and the version I
built is in orange.
And yes-- and then
the x-axis there
is latency in milliseconds.
And the y-axis is percent
of overall requests.
And so what this is showing
is a standard distribution
of latency as you would expect
from any distributed system.
Mandy's is centered
around 1 second
and mine is centered
around three seconds.
So I think you might
be right Mandy.
I think there may be something
wrong with my version.
Let's drill in and see
if we can understand why.
I'm going to look at a sample
trace from one of Mandy's.
And you can see here a breakdown
for one particular request.
It breaks down every millisecond
of where the time is spent.
So there was a little bit of
time spent, 44 milliseconds,
in metadata call to the GCVM.
That's probably authentication.
There was 50 milliseconds
sent in cloud storage.
And then 242 milliseconds
in the vision API.
So you can see that
this view gives you
an intuitive understanding
of how much those
RPCs you're doing cost.
But overall that looks
really fast, Mandy.
Let's go and take a look at one
of the slower ones from mine.
And you can see
it's a lot longer
and there's a lot more going on.
In particular there's this do
questionable initialization
method in there.
MANDY WAITE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRAD ABRAMS: That
may be questionable.
And you can see what it's doing
is it's doing a bunch of chain
calls to Twitter.
So that's clearly a mistake
that I made in my app.
Luckily as a developer this
tells me exactly where to go,
scavenger hunt line 11.
So that's right in here.
And you can see sure enough
we're calling Twitter in here.
Clearly something I should
work on right after this demo.
MANDY WAITE: This
isn't in the app
you're trying out by the way.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, exactly.
That was not push to production.
OK.
The next tool I want to
show you is error reporting.
So your many
distributed applications
get lots of errors.
But they get buried
into logs that you never
look at and can't find easily.
What Stackdriver error reporting
does is it looks in logs
and it pulls out
the relevant errors.
It's very intelligent about
the way it groups the errors.
So it isolates them to ones
that have the same root
cause associated with them.
And then it gives
you a frequency,
how often is that
happening, who's affected,
to help you triage
what to go work on.
So this one in
particular is type error,
cannot read property
of type name.
OK you can see it's
happening pretty regularly.
And we actually see
a full call stack
of where this is happening.
In particular it's
happening in AppJS.
And let me just start
real quick-- whoops.
The debug script.
I'm going to just throw some
sample load at it that will
reproduce exactly this issue.
So we've used this
tool now and we've
isolated where the problem is.
Now I could go back in the
source code and look at it.
But I want to show
you another tool.
The tool I want to show you
is the Stackdriver production
debugger.
So what we're going to do
with the production debugger
is we're actually going to
look at the running state
of the application
while it's running.
And so you can upload
your source code just
from your local machine.
You can attach a git-repo to it.
Or I'm using the free
private git repository
that comes with
the cloud platform
that you're welcome to use.
And you can see we have a
few versions of this app.
But I'm going to use the one
that I deployed as alpha 2.
And as you recall
it was line 577.
Right here is the
problem, line 577.
There's a nice
little helpful hint.
There's a bug here.
MANDY WAITE: That's handy.
BRAD ABRAMS: Doesn't
your code have that?
And so what we're doing is
we're setting a watch point.
This is a lot like a breakpoint
but it doesn't break.
Imagine if you had a
debugger and you attached it
to a running process.
That wouldn't be good.
This is something we use across
Google and many services.
Oh, and I have to-- sorry.
I have to actually
debug alpha 2.
So let me just do
that real quick.
I was debugging alpha 1
which is Mandy's version.
As we know her version
is really good.
It doesn't have
the problem in it.
So let me grab that.
OK.
Let's try again.
So you can't really
attach a real debugger.
The alternative
is logging, right.
Like if we were trying
to track this down
we might say we don't
have enough logging here.
We need to add more
logging, redeploy the app,
and then spelunk the logs again.
But that's also a very
difficult thing to do.
So instead we can
just set a snapshot.
And that pauses execution of the
program when that call happens
and then returns the results
so we can take a look at it.
So in this case the problem
seems to be line 57.
It was something about can't
access name of undefined.
So my guess is it's something
with this labels array.
Maybe the labels
array is not there.
But I can look at it.
There's the labels array.
It's got a name, flooring.
And a confidence of 72.
So that's not
really the problem.
Can anybody spot
the problem yet?
Maybe you need some more
help from the Cloud debugger.
I am curious about what
this labels length is.
I have a little bit of a theory
that what the problem might be.
So I can send and
expression there.
And just while we're
doing this I'll
also take a look at
what that index is.
So now it's going back
out to all those machines
and it's waiting for the first
time that error happens again.
And it's going to grab the stack
in locals and bring that back.
And there you can
see the length is one
and the sample index is four.
Can anybody see what the
problem might be now?
Come on.
Somebody yell.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah,
but what is it?
What's the problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Array index out of bounds.
So imagine how
long it would have
taken you to isolate
that without the help
of this sort of tool.
We can come back here.
We can actually see there's
the problem right there.
Sample index is set to four.
MANDY WAITE: We can have
better code reviews.
BRAD ABRAMS: Better.
We should really do
some code reviews.
Absolutely.
OK.
So I think we're ready to
switch back to slides now.
Aren't we, Mandy?
MANDY WAITE: I think we are.
BRAD ABRAMS: I showed
you three tools.
I showed you Stackdriver
trace for RPC profiling.
Then I showed you
Stackdriver error
reporting to help you
find out what's really
going on in terms of errors.
And then I showed you
the production debugger.
And so I think Mandy
is going to wrap us up.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
So quick wrap up.
We have a-- I like these things.
I like walking around
and prowling stages.
So, yeah.
So we have a quick wrap up.
We have lots more to come
when it comes to Google Cloud
Platform here.
What we've shown you today,
Brad has talked to you
about how Google
Cloud Platform is
a different kind of cloud, how
it differentiates effectively.
We've also walk
through how you can
have a productive
local development
experience using the very
simple tooling that we have.
All the things we ran locally
ran running standard tools.
We were running nodemon
and MPM and such
like to run our application
before we deployed.
We also have demonstrated many
of the flexible deployment
options basically coming
from having container images.
We can deploy that same
container image to App Engine,
to Kubernetes, or to anywhere
you run a container image.
And also Brad finally shows
you how we can greatly
reduce the time to fix.
And there's a lot
more to it as well.
Brad talked earlier about this
being the third wave of Cloud
platforms, of cloud computing.
And I think that's
never really been
more apparent than when
it comes to data analytics
in Google Cloud.
We have a very, very
extensive portfolio
of products when it
comes to data analytics.
We wanted to
demonstrate them today
in context of the application
but we just didn't have time.
It turns out we have more
time than we thought.
So what we decided
to do, and also we're
really good at doing
this data analysis.
We've been doing this
for a very long time.
So we have an extensive
suite of tools you can use.
And we have some talks
at Google I/O that
will cover these in detail.
So we have Kaz is
going to talk about how
to build a smart RasPi Bot
using the cloud Vision API
and also the speech
API later today.
Also there's making sense
of IoT data with the Cloud
from Ian Lewis
later on on Crater.
And also tomorrow
in the afternoon
we have Dominic
Preuss who's talking
about scaling your data
from concept to petabytes.
And also on Friday
we have Felipe Hoffa
and Jordan Tigani who will be
talking about the election.
And hopefully having
shown you how data
can predict the
results of elections.
I'm hoping they
won't be predicting
the result of
election but they'll
show you how you could
potentially do it.
And ultimately that's it.
But also we have another
session at 3:00 this afternoon.
The next session we're
trying to link them all
to drive you there so you
know where to go next.
So for your next Google
Cloud Platform talk,
go to Crater stage at
3:00 this afternoon.
Aja Hammerly is
going to be talking
about just enough
Stackdriver to sleep well
at night which kind of ties
back into what Brad has just
shown you.
We also have code labs.
So if you're interested
in getting hands
on with all of this stuff
that we've shown you today
including the
vision API, then you
can go to the code labs area.
We have 8 code labs.
You can come and see us
on the cloud sandbox.
We have the emoti booth
running which we first
featured at GCP next.
And that will effectively
detect facial expressions
and is a really,
really cool demo.
And also we had the
BigQuery query at demo
which again is also cool.
You can play with your
friends and it shows you
how BigQuery works.
And finally, we have
Cloud office hours.
So we're probably going to
run out of time for questions.
We should be able
to take a couple.
But if you have any
burning questions
or want to discuss anything
in depth with experts, Brad
and I will also
be there as well,
you can come to the Cloud
office hours today at 5 o'clock,
tomorrow one o'clock,
and Friday at 9 AM.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate you coming.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you.
Cheers.